look man I'm an artist I made that
picture of Elon I'm sorry of Donald
Trump and some Hedgehog running in
Washington DC you had a beret on as you
did it well you know if look if someone
uses a paintbrush to make an image
they're using a tool to do it we don't
we it's still their image now at the
point where the the the the canvas and
the paintbrush is literally just an AI
you tell it what to make you refine it
it is your art and it feels a lot of
people probably disagree but we're not
going to be thinking that in 10 20 years
people are going to be like that was so
creative creative of you to make that
movie they're back Sheamus that that
feature-length film you made last night
was incredible I I enjoyed the whole
thing thanks I enjoyed it too no problem
I appreciate it but you're you're going
to say you're all by myself actually
right now check it out they have apps
where you can animate images
you can post a picture of a person and
then type send in text or I play an
audio file and it will sync the the
photo with the audio file we've already
seen the stuff where people are singing
right we did the music video genocide
where we had like Taylor Lorenz singing
Our Song